hi everyone
my name is shawn i'm the pm for enthused
multi-cloud
and i'm really glad to have the
opportunity to be here virtually with
all of you today
to talk about modernizing and managing
your apps with answers
a pain point that we consistently hear
from customers
is that they have a lot of legacy apps
running on older infrastructure using
older frameworks
and that have become hard to maintain
customers are looking for a platform to
help modernize
these older apps as well as leverage the
modern best practices
for their new apps and this is where
enthos comes in
enthos is an application modernization
platform
that helps teams move faster and at
scale
with anthos you can modernize your apps
in place
on primary cloud you can automate policy
and security at scale
for all of your apps and you get a
consistent
operational experience across all of
your deployments
and those it's designed to be deployed
wherever you deploy your apps
you can use it to build an application
platform on top
that abstracts away many
platform-specific details
the vast majority of enterprises today
are operating in a hybrid or multi-cloud
environment
a lot of customers want the flexibility
to choose different environments
for different apps while reducing
operational overhead
some workloads must run on-prem due to
security and regulatory reasons
other workloads have been designed to
take advantage of certain best-of-breed
solutions
from specific cloud providers
and beyond that many customers want
their apps to be able to run on any
cloud
and sometimes be able to simultaneously
run on multiple clouds
many customers want to be able to burst
from on-prem to the cloud
or failover from one cloud provider to
another
or load balance between multiple clouds
and do all of this in order to achieve
resiliency goals
cost savings and reduce vendor locking
to enable these hybrid multi-cloud use
cases ethos is highly optimized
for many deployment environments with a
consistent operational experience
that takes all of them into account
on prem we support vms running on vmware
vmware vsphere with bare metal support
coming soon
we interoperate with a large number of
storage and networking providers
so the platform can easily integrate
with your existing infrastructure
in the cloud we integrate with cloud
specific services
such as load balancers private virtual
clouds
virtual private clouds and identity and
access management
gcp and aws are currently fully
supported
with azure support coming soon
at the mobile edge we're partnering with
telecommunications companies
and providing a deployment option that's
optimized for the small footprint
large fleet size and the unique
networking requirements of that
environment
now on top of this distributed
infrastructure
ethos provides the tooling and the best
practices built in
for all different members of your team
for infrastructure operators we provide
a unified experience
for managing your kubernetes clusters
in your environments along with the
configuration policies required
to meet your enterprise security and
compliance needs
for service operators we provide a way
to gain visibility and control
of your services including traffic
management
authentication authorization monitoring
and alerting
and for developers we provide ways to
easily deploy
and run modern serverless workloads
without needing to learn about the
underlying infrastructure
all these components are built on open
source foundations
much of which was first developed at
google
with enthos we put the lego pieces
together
to give you a managed and supported
experience for your infrastructure
so that you can focus on your unique
business logic so let me show you in a
demo
a bit more about how all this works
we'll first look at some details of the
individual clusters
and then we'll take a look at the
unified management experience provided
on top
here i have created four enzo clusters
the first one is a gke cluster on aws
the second one is an eks cluster
also on aws
and the bottom two are gk clusters on
gcp
and those on aws just reached ga status
recently
and we've heard of a lot of customer
interest here so let's take a quick look
at how gke integrates with the aws
environment
under the hood the cluster is running as
a number of ec2 vms
in aws cluster control plane
consists of three vms that can be
deployed in a highly available fashion
as we have it here across three
availability zones
in the same region
the other three vms here belong to a
single
node pool deployed in a single
availability zone
you can also add in additional node
pools and put them in different
availability zones in that same region
note here that none of these nodes have
public ip addresses
for security reasons most of our
customers prefer
that the clusters are available only on
an internal network
and can only be accessed via a vpn or
similar mechanism
a lot of customers have well-established
aws vpcs
that have been through rigorous security
reviews
so gke is designed to be able to install
into the customer's own vpc
and stay within the established
boundaries
from a management perspective we're
starting with the foundation
that most customers are already familiar
with just like the kubernetes-based apps
that you deploy
and manage gke clusters and other and
those resources
can also be defined declaratively in a
yaml file
which can be stored in source control
and they can follow
similar processes like code reviews and
have manual approvals
before deployment additionally
you can enforce policies on it using the
same tools
that you use to enforce policies on apps
define enamel files
for example here is the yaml file i used
to define the gke cluster on aws that we
saw
we define here what region the cluster
should run in
what vpc to use what subnets to use
and so on with this
customers can then layer policies on top
such as to enforce
that only certain vpcs may be used for
gke clusters
now zooming out a bit we've just briefly
explored
how gke integrates with a native
environment
specifically in the case of running on
aws
you may be wondering how we provide a
unified operational experience
on top of such a large variety of
cluster deployment
that journey starts with a unified
authentication experience
many customers have standardized on a
few top identity providers
for their corporate authentication needs
such as microsoft active directory
opta and others
gke clusters support oidc openid connect
so that customers can authenticate using
the same familiar
corporate credentials to all of their
clusters across
all their deployment environments
instead of using gcp accounts for some
clusters
aws accounts for other clusters and so
on
let's see how this works
here i registered my gke on aws cluster
but i haven't yet authenticated to it
let's click the login button
in this case we're using octa as our
example corporate identity provider
so i'll enter in my octa credentials
here
and now i'm logged in
the process is similar on the command
line and also works the same way for
other and those clusters
after authentication i can now use this
web console
to see information about the cluster
i can see the nodes that make up the
cluster
and information about each node such as
the pods running on that node
now so far we've explored running gke on
aws
that's one option for running your
workloads you can also run gke
on other clouds or in your own data
center
you can attach your own existing eks or
aks cluster to enthos
and you'll soon be able to bring vms to
enthos as well
for example the second cluster i have
here in the web console
is an aws eks cluster that's been
registered
to my anthos environ an administrative
domain for anthos resources
once registered you can run the same
higher level and those services on top
such as configuration and policy
management as well as service management
with this option customers can keep
using their existing kubernetes
distribution
and can more easily onboard onto enthos
while relying on google to test and
support the integrated solution
aws eks and azure aks are supported
today
and more distributions will be supported
in the future
now if and when you'd like to move to
gke you'll get many additional benefits
you'll get a kubernetes distribution
backed by the company that created
kubernetes
and with the most experience in managing
it it'll be the same kubernetes
distribution everywhere with same
networking and identity stack
many of the same security features and
so on
you'll get a more consistent experience
for managing the cluster
and its life cycle
now switching gears we've just seen how
anthos provides a consistent management
experience
to access all my clusters across
deployment environments
beyond access many customers also need a
way to ensure
that their policies and configuration
can be applied across all clusters
reliably and uniformly and this is where
acm
and those configuration management comes
in
with acm you can have all of your
cluster configuration policies
defined in the central git repository
and that will be synchronized
and applied across all of your endless
clusters
this gives you a way to easily manage a
fleet of clusters
and prevent drift with continuous
monitoring
using git as the source of truth you can
manage your configuration
policies as code with the power of
source control
so you can integrate code review flows
be able to easily audit changes
and you can easily revert back to
previous versions
many of our customers use acm to apply
and enforce policies like
limiting host os access as well as
limiting container repo access
and shutting off external ingles
for this demo i've configured all four
of my clusters
to pull the configuration and policies
from the same git repo
they're all pulling from the same git
branch and they've all updated to the
latest commit
clicking into one of them
the git repo url is configured here
and the subdirectory we're using is
configured here
if i navigate to this git repo
and then the subdirectory
i can see the configuration and policies
that are being applied
specifically in this cluster directory i
have the cluster-wide configuration
policies
for example we have a policy here that
requires that all namespaces
have a cost center label for auditing
purposes
going back there's also a namespaces
directory
that defines a few namespaces that will
be managed by acm
for example in this file we create a
shipping dev namespace
with a cost center label
switching back to the terminal
we see that the shipping dev namespace
has been created by acm
let's see what happens if we try to
delete that namespace
we see that the namespace was deleted
and then immediately recreated by acm
about three seconds ago so acm
is constantly monitoring to make sure
that what's deployed
matches the source of truth in your git
reboot
now what if we were to try to do
something that violates our policies
we saw earlier that there's a policy
requiring that all namespaces have a
cost center label
if we try to create a namespace that
doesn't have such a label
this action is denied and the namespace
does not get created
with our cluster configuration and
policies in place
the next thing we might want to set up
is our ci cd pipeline
for this one simple option is to use
google cloud build
our fully managed serverless ci cd
platform
with google cloud build you can easily
define pipelines
consisting of arbitrary build steps run
as container images
they can be automatically triggered from
your source code repository
and run on google's infrastructure
for this demo i've set up a really
simple pipeline here
that performs three steps
first we do a git clone of the
kubernetes examples repo
then we update the service definition to
use a service of type load balancer
instead of node port
and finally we configure cube cuddle
and use it to deploy the guest book
sample app
now let's kick off the deployment
while it's running let's view the
progress in the web console
here we can see the three steps and the
output from each step
notice that we deployed this app to our
enthos gke on aws cluster
so while your cicd pipeline can be
running on google cloud
you can use it to deploy to any ethos
cluster including clusters on prem
and in other clouds
in this case our cluster is actually
sitting in a private vpc
in aws we're able to access it
because there's an agent running in that
cluster
that reaches outbound google cloud to
maintain a persistent connection
we didn't need to open up any firewalls
or expose any public ip addresses
for that cluster this ability to proxy
kubernetes control plane traffic
is currently in alpha
so this pipeline is pretty simple and it
finished quickly
you can of course include many more
steps such as steps that build container
images
run validation and unit tests and so on
all within this fully managed service
let's now move to the kubernetes page in
the web console
we can select the cluster to view
and we see here that our guestbook
workload has been deployed
in addition our guestbook service is
also running
and an aws elb elastic load balancer
has been allocated
we can click into that
view the guestbook which is currently
empty
and add an entry to it
with this cloud build integration you
can build your app once
using our serverless ci cd platform and
deploy it across multiple clouds
for customers that need to build jobs to
be able to access
private resources or need more
configurability
we're also offering a new feature called
custom worker pools
currently in limited beta where you can
run builds in your private network on
gcp
using vpc network peering
now after we've deployed our apps one
more thing we might want to do
is to be able to monitor them enthos
makes this easy with asm
and those service mesh which is our
managed version
of the open source seo project
with asm service operators can gain more
visibility and control
over your services including traffic
management
authentication authorization monitoring
and alerting
for this demo i deployed a sample online
boutique app
a few days ago on my two gke clusters on
gcp
with the asmui we can see at a glance
how all of our services are doing
we can also drop into a topology view to
see how the services communicate with
each other
from here we can drill into each service
to get more information about that
service
we can see any slos we set for the
service
as well as a lot of metrics for the
service
such as requests per second
error rate latency
request size and so on
as of the latest release gke clusters on
gcp
can be part of the same service mesh so
they can load balance between them
and we can aggregate the metrics for the
services running on them
so the metrics we see here are
aggregated from both of our gke clusters
that are on gcp
if we want we can also break this down
by cluster
to monitor each cluster separately
for example let's do that for this
latency graph here
with this view we can see how the
services in each cluster
perform relative to each other the red
line represents one cluster
and the blue line represents the other
taken together these monitoring and
multi-cluster capabilities
make asm a great tool for operating your
services
note though that these capabilities are
currently only available
for gke clusters on gcp and will be
coming soon to end those clusters
running on prem
and on other clouds
to wrap up we just saw in the demo today
how we can bring workloads running on
other clouds to anthos
whether you choose to use gke or another
kubernetes distribution
we saw a unified authentication and
management experience
from the web console we applied the same
configuration policies
to all of our clusters we deployed an
app to a gke cluster on it
on aws using google cloud build
and we saw how we can use antho service
mesh to monitor the services
running in our clusters there's a lot
more we didn't have a chance to cover
today
so check out the other sessions this
week as well as our website
thecloud.google.com
thanks for watching and stay safe